um
okay hi everyone my name is evelyn i'm
currently a second year just finished my
second year incoming third year phd
students
um in memorial catering in new york city
um so my research is currently is
involving studying
um epigenetic regulation of um
anti-tumor immune response i know it's a
lot i don't know it's a lot of
strange words and really like you know
not many people actually understand that
so i'm writing down here
so my overall body interest is intense
immunology which is a very broad fill
to say that we study how immune cells
interact with cancer cells
my interaction would mean that you know
how do they
see each other how to respond how do
they perceive
do they ignore do they get the call and
with the overarching goal of
trying to educate the immune system or
to use our immune system to fight cancer
that's a simplest way of of phrasing
that
in addition my previous um research
in prior to joining msk was working with
antibodies which is why i'm excited to
talk to you about antibodies
today um my previous lab i worked in
sort of like this
engineer antibodies how to make them
better uh to make them different
different cool stuff um put drugs onto
antibodies and use it as an imaging
agent
um so that's what um my previous um
research was about i think with the
current setting of covet i think you
probably have um heard or seen a lot of
immunology
um words and like phrases and then you
might you know wonder what that means
and i hope that after this class we can
you know
understand the newspaper a little bit
better more like scientific and not just
you know
um you know just just newspapers so
um my interest other than research is
mostly traveling i also do a little bit
of yoga
i cook i think that's a lot of this
activities uh
i'm born born out of the kovit but um
you know traveling is still there and
you know dying to
to get back um on the plane sometimes um
but these are my email address if you
have any questions after it's class
today you want to get in touch you want
to connect with me
these are my email address
call should we get started okay
so i think before i wanted to to um
get an idea of what you guys know about
immunity and protection
uh if you can type um on the uh on the
chat
maybe um you can just let me know what
you guys
think immediate protection means um
because you know that's
really relevant to what we actually
talking about these days right
um so maybe it's just kind of like no
okay guys so this is your do now type in
the chat
what is immunity what do you think
is the meaning of the word immunity or
maybe the word protection
i want to see everybody typing something
in the chat
uh can i say that and do i have the type
yes oh yeah you can say you can say
something yeah
okay uh i mean the word protection is
another
meaning of immunity is like so basically
being
being being protected from something or
being uh
yeah being protected so what do you
think we we're getting protected from
various things i mean uh viruses is one
of them
getting sick yeah virus is really good
um right
um things that make us sick right yeah
so that's what
we know most about the immune system is
that it's such a
vague broad you know shield that
protects
our body from invasion from pouring
things around us right
so that's a really good definition to
get started and then i want to show you
oh i don't know how do i get the next
slide
so the immune system that's what we
think is a shield
uh that fights that's most people think
about the initiative is fighting agent
but in reality the immune system is such
a complex network of everything that is
in the body of different organs
different
fluids different things that have two
main
um goal one is to fight prevent
and heal i think unless many people
don't think of immune system as healing
um but it's actually very crucial to
actually have
that kind of um balance in terms of
fighting and healing that keep
ourselves healthy and normal um
so do you know what happens when the
immune system is not go
it's not really doing good job healing
us or it's too sensitive or it's
not you know it's actually trying to
attack ourselves
you know what what we get when that
happens
you can unmute and um chat as well as
you can type in the chat
so we're looking at the question at the
bottom of the slide now what happens
when the immune system is too
sensitive anybody have any ideas
it's okay you don't know that's totally
fine because it's not really the
question we talk about usually
so what happens i don't know
so we get allergies we get allergies
with autoimmune diseases we get things
like lupus we have things that you know
we
sneeze out when spring is calm we some
people can't eat peanuts some people
can't tolerate milk a dairy um so that
is when
the immune system is too sensitive and
it's not really
doing a good job of healing so overall
wanting to know about immune system is
not only to fight
as we most know in terms of cultural
situations but also prevent
from a future attack as well as heal us
after
we fight off an invasion so
with the main topic today when i when i
is antibodies right um antibodies is a
part of the immune system
and i try to kind of look up on google
what it
means when you guys look up antibody and
these are um
for example oxford languages say that
it's a blood protein
produced in response to encountering a
specific antigen so first of all what is
an antigen
antibodies combine chemically with
substances which the body recognizes in
alien
et cetera et cetera then
i think this is a near western it's say
something more words complicated words
and i feel like definition should make
things
easier to understand not become more
complicated to understand i think it
defeats the purpose of trying to
find something um so they're not wrong
but they're just very complicated and it
doesn't really
orient us um to way to understand it so
i decided to kind of you know this is
what where we are now so we know the
antibodies are part of the immune system
they're found in the body they give us
immunity as protections
we just talked about and they work
during infection or invasion by
bacterial viruses what we just talked
about right
so these are where we are so i hope by
the end of class we can broaden it to
this
kind of question to a way that is more
related to
um you know scientific terms so
that's why we are an antibodies a part
of the immune system
but in fact is a protein that is
secreted by a type
of immune cells called b cells here um
or plasma cells plasma cell is
mature b cells um these are the cells
that make up antibodies because
you can think of antibody just like kind
of like this little
round circles and the secret inside the
body and it's made by something
and that's something is the cell it's
called b cell
and this b cell designed antibodies to
recognize
a very specific target called antigens
of antigens into targets i'm just going
to refer them as targets for the rest of
the
of the clustered ages for simplicity and
so the
main role of antibodies is recognition
that's what we all need to know about
recognition recognize
and it works as a key and lock system as
you can see this you have
the yellow key for the yellow lock the
brow key for the round lock
and antibodies are the same they are
made to design
um they make to to recognize and
identify a very specific target
right so and then different um
antibodies uh these are different
classes antibiotics they look different
but even though you see these like
different igg ed
m a they look different so can you tell
me
what is the similarity so what's the
common thing of these
different antibodies of different
choices antibodies do you think
you find something that these have in
common there's a hint
uh it's about the shape
it's another shape
it's okay so this is the next slide you
guys don't have to answer now so the
common thing about these all these
classes bodies is they are
y-shaped they look like a y so basically
that's um
what antibodies look like and the first
six things in the
what you're looking at uh just different
ways that scientists
usually draw out to identify antibodies
so the first one here is the most
sympathetic way and most people identify
or when they draw antibodies and why and
it gets a little more complicated about
the structures where it
comes from what it does the chemist
called bonds and
all this cool stuff is getting more
complicated and complicated
um but what i wanted to know that is
part of the white ship is very important
because
um there's an arm right there's two arms
and a tail
the arms of the antibodies here as you
can see
is what by a certain target for an
antigen
so you see it engages with antigen here
and that's the the arms each of the arm
can also bind to
to the same or different angles and it's
a tail
the tail part is also very important to
interact with other immune cells or
components of the immune system
so it sometimes can work alone sometimes
we'll get others but if we know
immune system is complex network of a
lot of things working together
um so that's about the
shifts of the antibody so my next
question is uh
we pull up the poll question uh
which part of the antibody is required
to recognize the target or which part of
interval you recognize the target
um could you guys um answer in the poll
take a guess you gotta take a guess so
the polls are anonymous so i won't know
if you guessed it incorrectly or
correctly
so if you see the poll on your screen
you can just choose one of the four
options um when about eighty percent of
you all
have done i'll stop before so i'll give
you all a few more seconds
we have about fifty percent who voted
we're waiting for another 50
so the options are two arms of a y
the tail of a y two arms of an
x and i don't know
that's totally a valid answer a lot of
times we don't know that's what we are
i wait for a few more folks to vote
i give you guys three more seconds three
two one awesome so we have a tie
so about forty percent thinks it's two
arms of a y
and forty percent thinks it's tail of a
lie and the rest of you all
have no clue
this is totally okay um yeah i know it's
it's first time you're seeing this you
know
strange um y-shaped things um
oh how do i move this point oh here we
go i can
so um i think about 40 you get it right
but it's totally not wrong that
you know the tail is very important in
terms of our antibodies work as well
but to recognize a target
as its main um function right it's
mostly at the arm
so the arms so you think about it's like
a person setting up with like two arms
um holding up like that and then the
hands the hands are what grabbing they
the target rabbit garbage antigen so
the hands are the arms here is what
recognize the target and the
tail basically this this situation is
helping you stand but
in the antibody setting it's also help
with interaction
so this is a very broad super super um
overarching question i don't think you
guys get it so this is a pure guessing
question um i think you guys have um
read the word neutralization and
neutralizing antibodies when you read
about
um covet vaccines or you know different
kind of
government vaccines are currently being
um applied
um so i wanted you to know um what the
word neutralization means
but um so try your guess um
awesome so we have four options on the
pole so the first one is
neutralization is injection by cell
eaters so we call those in
science macrophages things that just go
around eating cells
or neutralization means to kill
um where you just burst the cell and
neutralization could mean
protection by blocking access of this
foreign
into the cell or i don't know okay so
i'll give you all a few seconds to
answer
we have one person who responded so
we're waiting on the rest of the group
so does neutralization means eating the
cell killing the cell or blocking
stuff from getting into the cell
we have about 50 voted
i'll give you all about 10 more seconds
we almost have 75 percent voted
great um i want to ask somebody who who
answered
protection by blocking access to to
explain to me what that means
um so what and why did you pick the
answer
so somebody can somebody tell me
why they picked protection by blocking
access
so feel free to write your response in
the chat and can give you about
5-10 seconds if you're brave enough feel
free to raise your hand on
yourself um
for me i do i i
i break down the word neutralization
this is the word i feel like
that is something related to where like
somebody
that it was uh i just imagined where
somebody
is getting a injection where like they
put
alcohol on their hand to make it
neutralized
wow that's very that's very good that's
that you're absolutely right that's
that's great
that's great the word neutralization
actually means what it means right it's
um
um yeah i'm glad but honestly what i
before i learned immunology you tell me
neutralization i would not know what
that means
i do not know that it's it's related to
antibody or it's related to some
classically means um
um components so let's uh
already i'm sorry i'm on this laser
pointer that it's making very very hard
to
do this um okay
so you're actually right so i just
wanted to go back to
that when we talk about how so anybody
gives you annuity right
so the way it does is either can prevent
infection or have fight against an
active infection
so the parts that it um help fight
sorry get interact with other immune
cells is here so when you engage with
other immune cells the macrophages that
uh 36 percent use picked um as
it's actually ingestion which means
engulfment eating by macrophages
or encasa which is another type immune
cell
that uh killed by lysis so it injects
something into the cell and the cells
burst out and then you die so here you
have the
um image here that you have an immune
cell that engages with an antibody the
antibodies then engage with an antigen
or target here bound on
on an infected cell so think about this
maybe it's viral viral protein virus
bacteria
and the antibody recognizes it then you
have immune cell coming and
recognize an antibody so that's a very
cool thing right so the immune cells our
immune system
interact with each other and help each
other fight off
um an invasion and then the cells
that has the virus is becoming infected
um isn't dyed um
a lot of you knew about this macrophages
injections so that's very cool right so
here is another situation when you have
antibodies here
as i said you know in scientific we
always draw antibodies as why
and it recognized a little circle here
that is on the surface of
the pathogen like the bacteria a microbe
here anything that small
pathogen and then you um what it does is
it actually binds to that
tail of the y that we talked about the
table right here isn't recognized by
this cell eater's
macrophages and then what it does is it
kind of like reach out
its entire arm and engulf everything in
it
and it digests um so that's one very
cool way
and a lot of you we already knew about
neutralization which is a process when
antibodies surround the target
like coronavirus right and block it from
access to a cell before it could cause
an infection that process is called
neutralization
so it's basically it's a basis of a lot
of you guys knew about covert vaccines
right that's what we
we have when um we use our immune system
to prevent an infection by a virus and
that what it is here so you see that it
blocks all access from this circle
brown shape here which is an antigen or
is it a virus or it can be
toxin it can be a lot of things and it
blocks it from access to a cell so it
causes an infection that is the process
neutralization and the last part here
i'm going to go
just to go really briefly because i
don't think you know it's not that
important but i think
it's be cool to know um that we think
antibodies are on the body
and we we think the antibodies work
during infection but the
reality is that we have different
classes of antibodies as i've shown
before right they're all
right shape they look different uh and
they are
very different but they found a
different part of the body
so this particular strange x shape here
that is made of two white shapes kind of
pouring the tails together
um they usually found in the mucus um so
you know
basically in your respiratory tract when
you um sneeze out and that kind of mucus
when you're like you're coughing
uh you're sneezing um that's when these
antibodies are found also in like the
lining of your stomach or your
intestines
that's where these particular antibodies
are found however
most of us know antibodies probably in
the blood that's what if you ask
somebody they probably
antibodies in the blood uh and i think
this um
igg antibody girl is most commonly found
uh and those longest lasting in the
blood so this different class of
antibodies are different
um they're found different parts of the
body and
um the very cool thing about like igg
for example
it's the most abundant because it's also
long and lasting
and it's the only antibody that can
cross the placenta
in to enter the fetus to protect the
baby um
during pregnancy and in addition to that
you can see the igg here
is a primary antibody that works during
allergies
so you can see that you know uh antibase
work in different settings will be
foreign infection
during an infection or after an
infection when you know you're cleaning
things off or you
meeting a new challenge or during
allergy so it's not really limited to
pathogen or bacteria or virus but we
think of immune system it's also
part of you know any response to the
foreign
um particles um or even without cells so
that's um the just the major ideas of
antibodies
so in moving on to the how antibodies
are in the labs it's what um
was very cool thing to look at this i
found this figure um
online and i felt it was very
comprehensive um
a lot of us when we work with antibodies
we work with different types of
antibodies
and we make antibodies useful to us in
the scientific setting we make
them the tools to use in the scientific
research rather than just you know
something that we in the body so if you
ask
um do you take do i take my antibodies
from my own body and then study it
no of course not but what we do is we
have commercial antibodies that are made
elsewhere they can be made
in the lab so the lab can also generate
antibodies
that are specific again for a specific
target of
specific purpose um so antibodies can be
used in the lab
as a tool for study of it uh to ask the
various expert questions
um the thing that i'm going to um
focus on today the part of the
scientific um
experiment i'm going to show you today
is um mostly
related to this major class of
antibodies called antibiotic conjugate
so what that means is that you can see
uh can anybody
like i think let me just move this
profession sorry
um so what it means that in this um
antibodies you're looking at the it's in
this red square here
that you see that in the tail of y it
has some star
some red or yellow stars and that means
the drug
or that means protein that means
something else that we scientists
put into onto the antibodies to make
them useful for us
so they could be um for example drugs so
we
use antibodies to carry those drugs and
then enter
the cells into the body to go to a very
specific place
or they can be um full of force for
first resident proteins what that means
is just
glowing proteins proteins that that glow
so it marks a certain colors
um so that is useful for us to when we
want to visualize something in the dark
right so we want to see where things are
um from the mysql
microscope we know where things are so
then we mark them by colors
um and are as very cool things here uh
very cool part of it
is that can also be linked to enzymes so
does
anybody know what enzymes do
or if you know an example of an enzyme
that you've heard or what you think it
does
feel free to type it in the chat or meet
yourself
and if not feel free to say you're not
sure
it's always okay to not know it's always
okay
that's very good
wow
it's a really good yes um enzymes are
just
parts of you know where they they create
reactions you're completely right
um wow somebody some speed of reference
you're really good
um because those are catalysts so the
the enzymes are
exactly what carry on assuring
um reaction right
so what i'm going to introduce today
with a mini lab
is um this particular technique called
eliza i think eliza is something that is
very easy for you to
remember um right so eliza everybody
can say that what it means is enzyme
linked enzyme-linked antibody basically
even with sorbent assay it's it's just
fancy way of saying we recognize
something cool
basically what we use is we have this
antibodies that
um are linked to an enzyme
um specifically you see in the green
ones here
which we're actually going to do later
on uh
together but the idea of elisa is that
you want to detect a particular
target for example you want to know if
you have
a pathogen you know you have a virus you
want to know if you have
what your blood type is it's what you
want to to
to recognize we want to figure out so
the idea of this is that you have an
antibody
recognizing it and the antibody is
actually coated
on the bottom of a well as you can see
here and in the picture
and coated it just means that you know
you are glazing something like a donut
so you have a sugar glaze in the donut
that's just coating and
basically that true glaze is is the
antibodies coating the well
then you interact with the antigen or
let's say here
um you know the pathogen or coronavirus
or anything that you wanted to see here
is captured by the antibodies at the
bottom of the well
and then you that's why it's a recognize
it
right and here you can see that it looks
a lot like neutralization we saw right
so
the antigen is a sandwich captured
between two
antibodies recognize the same then
there's another antibody that recognizes
antibodies
you see that the green white shape here
is recognized the tail of this blue
antibody here
and that green antibody is conjugated
with an enzyme
the enzyme of this antibody catalyze
the reaction that changes the color
of the well so that changes of color
infers that you have captured the
antigen in the well so there is
something cool interesting as
well right and if you don't see the
change color here that
means that these antibodies have not
detected anything that means you don't
have anything so you're negative
let's say you are negative for um
antigen
of target abc [ __ ] that means you may be
um an old type light for example that's
a different setting so
anyways it's very simplified it just
means that you have no
target in the well so what we are going
to do together
let me actually share the screen
can you all see my screen
so now i think how do we when you can
stop the presentation and then i can
spotlight your screen
there we go all right so i'm gonna
can everyone see through the camera
phone
awesome so what we're going to do is
we're going to put gloves on
because you need to protect yourself
right and then i'm going to put my
camera
here hopefully you'll see my my um
bench you see here
so these
are well that i
have prepared yesterday
um and these are what we saw from my
um for my slides and you have the wells
and the wells here are coated with
antibodies at the bottom
and i have pulled the antigen here or
the target yesterday and intubated them
so hopefully if it works i've never done
this overnight
um on the next day so let's see if it
still works so
this is the elizabeth what i'm going to
do
stays is that we have here color asian
a right and this is color asian b
so we're going to mix these two together
these are the substrates of an
anti-enzyme
right so we talked about enzymes
catalyzed or they they
create reactions right so the enzymes
already on the antibodies here
on the well and we are going to make the
substrate and we're gonna hopefully see
a reaction so what i want to do is i'm
going to use this black tubes um
here and the reason why we have black
tubes is because they
uh this when we mix this together they
become sensitive to light
so what i'm going to do as you can see
these are different types
um they have different numbers here you
know different kind of volumes
so what we're going to do is we're going
to use this fake pipettes as the biggest
tips right here and it's this is pipet
or this skinny
ram thing um is very
useful in the last setting because you
can you know change the volume you can
use different ammo
so these are the tips the tips look like
this they have a little bit of a filter
and then what we're going to do
is we'll mix
these together so this is
oh no this is not the right one so read
the label always with the label before
you start
okay so i'm going to do is
so when you become a scientist you kind
of know how to open and close in with
one hand
so i'm going to mix things here
okay you can't really see the liquid in
here
this is when you have to kind of trust
yourself and then you know
stress it is in here what i'm going to
do is i'm going to briefly
mix this
and then what we're going to do
is we're going to add 200 microliter
each of this mixed solution of a and b
into the well
hopefully see
something
so um a wave how to do
color changes so you put it on a white
background like this
do you see that the first one changed
color
what color are you all starting to see
in the
in the well that looks like it's
changing
like light blue yeah
what about the others you see anything
in the other wells
that one likes to be here yeah
so what we can do is we can um cover
this
and go back to the presentation for a
little bit discussion and we'll go back
to here
let me this is a very positive way i
haven't found a rack that fits this tube
so
we're gonna put them here
and then we distribute it across so
it's here but we can go back into the
presentation now
and and while she goes back to the
presentation y'all can think about
whether or not it will get a darker blue
if it's going to change to another color
or if it's going to go back to clear
just keep that in mind
okay
can you all hear me
yes yes okay cool
so i want to put my camera here um
the next slide is a question that um i
wanted to ask you
from this um
a graphic that i showed you what do you
think
um what principle antibodies allows
for elisa works what does it serve as
the basis of
elisa so one is antibodies especially to
the target
two an antibody can bind to
or recognize other antibodies and the
last is
um antibodies could be linked to other
stuff like drugs versus proteins enzyme
are all be above
all right so i just launched a poll with
the same question so what is the
principle of antibodies
in the elisa city eliza is the procedure
that she just completed
and so the options are antibodies are
specific to their targets
or an antibody can bind or recognize
other antibodies
or antibodies can be linked to other
stuff like the fluorescence like the
colors different drugs different
proteins
or all of the above
so i'll give you a few moments to fill
out the poll
so thinking about what she just talked
about and what um
she showed choose what you think best
fits
i want to open this
easier for people to visualize
yeah about 50 who voted
wait for a few more and then we can end
the poll and see what the top answer is
anyone else wants to take a guess we
have 60 percent
i'm gonna end the poll in five four
three two one
awesome so out of seventy percent who
voted about
sixty percent of you decided that the
answer was
d all of the above share those results
that's the correct answer all the above
very good guys so we know that
antibodies are specific to the targets
right
so basically what it means is that um
these antibodies the orange and the blue
recognize the specific
um fret antigen here not the great ones
right so it's supposed to be the targets
and it can bind to other antibodies you
see the green ones actually
it's bound to to the blue uh antibodies
and they can be linked or they
contribute it's a scientific word for to
other stuff
and that is what we saw that is linked
with an enzyme
that um catalyze the reaction of
color changes that we just saw in the
well
um yeah so that's so just a very simple
um
basis of elisa
one application of this principle elisa
as we can see
this is blood tests so we now we know
what antibodies
are what they do uh how they do it
then we started to understand how they
applied
um you know normally not in only the lab
but
in hospital and different research and
medical settings
so what it's um blah blah test actually
it's uh they have different antibodies
against different antigens right or
targets
so here you have a red blood cells you
have different infertile cells here
they are bounded they are they bound by
different antigens so
a antigen b antigen a and b are none
then what we do is we detect those
antibodies using specific antigens
against either
b or a so basically um what we saw here
is that you if you have
blood zero then you have no antigens
right
so when you have anti a antb you don't
see
the bound however when you see when you
have
engine um a for example and you
use antigen b it would not recognize
and vice versa
so that's basically just an application
of
what it means when we understand
antibodies what is
in the detection and diagnosis kind of
setting
so this is the last question i have in
the class um
we can talk about this before while
we're waiting for the well
um but this is a very open-ended
question and i think it's like the first
question i saw with the class
uh it's kind of you know to to for you
to um a little bit
um further the um your thoughts about
antibodies so
if your friend cause virus x we're not
going to say the name here
virus x is whatever embarrassed and your
friend has also caught virus x
does it mean both you and your friend
have the same antibodies
i'll give you a moment to digest the
question so
evelyn's asking if you and your friend
both caught the same virus
and would you both have the same
antibodies
all right so you can put yes no with an
explanation in the chat
or if you're feeling brave
you could unmute and say it
uh okay
uh definitely not not a straightforward
um question so i'll take your time
meanwhile i'm going to check the web
really quickly and i could just bring it
over here
go ahead uh usual is that how you
pronounce your name
uh-huh i feel like the answer is no
because
uh since antibodies are like
uh things uh that we our body produces
inside inside the body right
and depending on even this
virus could be same but the genetics or
of the virus can be different based on
that
our body can like the mutation you could
call it and then
a body can have to produce a
similar kind of uh
and
okay i like where you're going with that
um and laura
fight device okay
sorry um so lara also mentioned that
antibodies work
different in different bodies um also
because blood type is not the same so
maybe what they produce is different
i like how you all are thinking anyone
thinks that it's going to be the same
who wants to debate
so what is uh why we are on this i'm
going to see
covers as well i think we should
by the end of the class we should be
able to see something cool
so i'm going to see most people think
that the antibody may be
different even though you're infected
with the same virus
so evelyn tell us what do you think
you guys are uh right you guys are
getting there um so what
um the question meant um was to ask is
whether you know we talked about the
specificity right we talked about
different interactions with other
parts of immune cells we talked about
you know antibodies can be made to
lose many different things um as a
scientist
um but when we go back into the question
of you know our cells
what it means to translate this question
to us um
when you call let's say you know virus
acts can be a part of the pandemic right
in all of us a lot of us got the same
virus essentially the antibodies
um will be different um
they first of all they can different
they can these antibodies
even though they recognize the virus
they recognize different parts
of the virus right so they can be
different parts even
if you have the same antibody as your
friend because you might have some
of them at this similar or the same some
of them can recognize the same part
of the virus so you and your friend have
a lot of
antibodies but maybe one of them is
similar or the same
um what similarity here is is when we
talk about recognition
but the different part here is mostly in
the
tail or the rest of the antibodies right
so two antibodies can recognize
the same target
does not mean they are the same
antibodies that's the idea of this
question
so if you have antibodies recognize the
same
target they can be completely different
antibodies
and that's um you know in
the lab we we know these antibodies are
different because maybe they're made
differently
they are made of different
um genetic makeup this is so one of you
can say um
touch on the genetic or the mutations
right so antibodies are very very
diverse
and um they are made to have a very
diverse recognition of different parts
of
a virus different parts of protein or
bacteria um
and even if they recognize the same the
rest of them would be different
so the answer is is no
so what i want to take you to take away
this question is that
if you have antibodies for cutting the
same target or the same antigen
they do not mean that the same
antibodies that's um just the overall
wrapping up of this question
and now i want to go back into the well
and then we're going to
see this reaction how it's going right
we're gonna see when this enzyme
reaction right
um and then we're gonna see with whether
we change
um we see any change in the colors
evelyn you can end the presentation so
we can
see your screen what do else yeah
perfect
and you'll see my um
yeah we can see the table
oh
can you all see it all right tell us
what you see
oh the camera went off again and there
we go
so the well to the far left we're gonna
call that one
the one in the middle we're going to
call that two and the one at the right
we're gonna call that three
can anyone tell us what what do you
observe
all of them have different color
so they're all different colors
does anyone want to have asses too wide
they're different colors
yeah that's a very good list
that's really good so do you know why
they're different
is there more of something less of
something you're not sure
yeah the colors are more deep you know
so i can read
so i can beat um your answer
you can unmute yourselves or type it in
the chat
oh and there's a possibility
uh i can't remember what we are going to
do because this reaction will
continue going on so when we go we're
gonna
say sorry we know what you're gonna
comment on the colors
i was just saying uh because of like
first we used two different type of
enzymes right
in order to make yeah right so because
there could be a possibility because of
it the color is different
okay so you think it has something to do
with the enzymes
so i think you are right so the
what um happened here is that um
i use the same um enzyme
basically for all three wells so they're
not different enzymes
um the different the only part that's
different as well
is that the first well here has
um the most antigens so it has a lot of
antigens here
the second well has less and the last
one has no antigen
that's when you see that eliza is a very
sensitive
technique that detects um the amount of
antigens
in in the well or the amount of targets
in the world
so this is what you see is a
the reaction that is um carrying by the
enzymes bound to the antibodies
that catalyzes the reaction chain so in
the lab we also
have something that is um the stop
solution
so what we're going to do is we're going
to stop this reaction
adding um
okay
it is magic i think of science as magic
all the time
so the reason why we need to have the
stop solution here is we want to stop
the reaction
right so we don't want it to be too blue
or too
um yeah like too so
basically we don't want to be too dark
of a blue so it like darkens up
and it changes the color to yellow here
so we would enable this to be detected
with a machine so this actually can be
read
on a machine in a very specific
wavelength
to read out the certain number
and this number correlates with the
amount
of the targets in the well
so do you see that so basically what it
means here is that yellow means that yes
antigen
more yellow is a lot of antigen and then
um and then white here means nothing in
there
awesome a quick question for you guys
because i also think about it when i
think of eliza's
so if you had three people who were
infected one person got infected on day
one
and you checked them on day one you
checked them on day 10.
and then he checked them before they
were infected
which one would be darker the day one or
the day 10.
laura said day 10 mark said day 10.
yeah right so you're thinking the longer
you're infected the more
viruses replicating in your body where
the more antigens are present
so the antibodies combined you guys are
on it so
um
if you guys don't need this i'm going to
show you guys here is here
well sometimes we'll use it i'm sorry
right so that's uh just how
eliza works essentially so um
because of the time that we have um i
wasn't able to carry the entire
experiment or the technique um it would
take like some time to like five hours
so
we have kind of condensed it to kind of
like half an hour um
10 minutes kind of cold color changes
and
that's one um very sensitive or one
really cool thing about um
antibodies so they are specific they're
very expensive they're very
sensitive and they're really stable so
um that's what we use in the lab and
um i think
i was going to show you a tour guide to
expenses
i think they are accidentally unmuted
um yeah i was going to give you a tour
of the lab but i think we don't have
time but
um before we leave i just wanted to
chat a little bit um you know as
you guys are in high school and i was in
high school once and that was when
i got excited about this stuff so
um yeah you know um
when i was in high school i see you guys
i was you know in
a lab for a summer and uh that's when i
first had my first exposure to science
back in the day we didn't have this kind
of zoom
you know classes we didn't have this
different kind of internet
enabled classes um so we kind of have to
see a lot of things in person
um and i worked in a lot back then we
what we did was we made
a low-cost h5n1 vaccine i know each five
and ones have so long ago
um but it was once another uh part of
you know the pandemic and the um the
respiratory virus that um
make us you know sick um and it was very
long ago but what we did was we made
um vaccines low-cost um
so using technology um and i was you
know amazed by everything that i was
i saw i uh everything that i saw i still
remember i
drew out thing on my notebook and my
notebook
i still have that is pink and it's like
super has like a different pink hearts
on on them and then
convinced me like you know pictures of
like scientific troops and like
things that i what i don't know because
i'm afraid that i will forget about them
that's why i have to write down
everything
um and then you know in the end i was
like you know
you know once you embark in on this
field of science that you
know these are things you need to know
but back in the time it looks like magic
to me it looks like
you know why do we need different kind
of tools
um and you know if you guys are
interested you know in science and
want to to um you know pursue as his
career in the future
um you know what i would think it's it's
the first thing you
have is curiosity and i think that that
any scientist will tell you that um you
know
when they stay on this path long and
longer they
um they remain curious they're curious
of different things and different
questions and
they pursue those questions um so that's
why you know asking questions
and thinking of questions um as very
important parts
of science um um
and you know and science can be
different thing it doesn't have to be
biology as
we talked about today doesn't have to be
immunology it doesn't have to be cancer
it can be you know chemistry physics any
other
parts that that you know allow us to
think um
critically and and and um creatively
so if you have you know the creative
aspect and you're curious
you know i think science would be a
great way
for you to to embark on in the future
um any questions for evelyn
um how did she get into science the work
that she
does um any other related
unrelated questions um feel free to
write it in the chat
or you can unmute yourself and feel free
to ask
uh
any questions on antibodies or elisa
sorry am i designing her my lab mates
and walking around carrying boxes and
and then you know things fall off and
stuff and it's loud and it's
yeah chaotic just what happens a lot
it's for like it's an open space
um so you see my co-workers like myself
as my
other aggressors here it's like what are
you doing
so it's a very open and collaborative
space
so lara wants to know what's the
difficult thing to be a scientist
um i think it's a lot of studying i and
i think bike about it
um it's uh it's being a student right i
think a scientist is a student
um student of science and and um
even though yeah we talk about it and we
teach and we
present and we publish and we do all
these cool things we discover
uh essentially we are students and and
studying is is
part of you know becomes the difficult
thing and into a passion
um i think in the past when i was
younger i didn't actually have the
patience to actually
study i i was you know a spontaneous
person i was you know
i was not into discipline i was not i
don't like being told what to do i don't
like principles
um and you know i was not made for
science at all i
study arts for the longest of time i
almost applied to art school when i was
in high school not major science and
then you know
um so the difficult thing is kind of
like
get yourself to study and i think what
changed in me was you know the
experience i got myself
exposed to um you know it could be what
you read it could be
what you watch it could be who you met
and the people around you
and that inspire you to want to learn
and i think that is the most important
thing that
that gets you on the path of studying
and
and for me that's that's the most
difficult thing
um this is long hours of studying
but it's uh knowledge becomes you know
something that if you
you want to pursue um and you know
because of that part signing you might
have to
to you know sacrifice a lot of things
you know when i was in in college for
example
um my convocation day which is like the
first day of
school my senior year instead of of
um going with my class to convocation
you know senior
college right we all like dress up and
like you know the entire school like
honors as being senior we're graduating
i was in a mouth surgery for seven hours
um
and i did not go to convocation so that
was something that
it's it's um you learn to do um
and then you want to do so um
and that i think that's something that's
inherent about it and the spontaneity
and the grit of studying that's the most
difficult thing
but the reward is great so the reward
is incredible so for example i always
tell
my friends this when i talk about what i
do is that sometimes
if you become a scientist and if you are
discovering something new and
at the moment when you discover it
for example you knew it and you saw it
think about you
maybe the first person in the world
knows what you know
right and then that's something that is
um
that is the kind of we call the high the
very high
um and the discovery part and the
learning and the knowing
and and the truth that it implies
because uh
you know we can talk about politics we
can talk about all these ideas
the science is for me it's it's truth
it's truth that can be replicated it's
true that it's basis and the foundation
of a lot of things around us
of the human body of the you know the
house of everything that is
that is true um so that's a reward
um but yeah the difficult thing is a lot
of setting if you're like not like
you're not a good student i mean i was
not a studious
um in my class either so
uh i had one more question about
uh what college did you went to
in high school and college high school i
assume right because we all know
what college industry oh college that i
went to um
i went to mount holyoke college i know
you guys knew the college is
in western mass uh it's where um the
same neighborhood with amherst college
smith college umass amherst um
it's in like a mountain or from the
western part of massachusetts
um that's where i went um yeah
and then i did most of my research i did
a umass amherst actually so i think
umass and host might be
um a bigger name that you might you
might recognize
not holocaust is kind of small um but
that's where i went to
and i honestly i tell you it's um it's
um
i wasn't actually into bio chemistry at
the beginning i actually
wanted to to do something differently um
so i
i was a pre-med student and then i
decided to pursue dietetics and
nutrition
for a couple of years um and then i
ended up
also was studying english literature at
the same time
so i ended up you know being this weird
combination of biochemistry
nutrition and english minor student
um with a thesis on something related to
macrophages and breast cancer
something like you know that's what
happens in college you
you find something you like and then you
want to pursue it and then you
you know there's a couple classes in bed
you're a minor in english
and that's you know that's what it ends
up
but um yeah i was a biochemistry
major um in my holocaust
nice any other questions
you know i'm i would love to talk about
anything if you guys
want to reach out to me um yeah i also
talk um every summer i teach a similar
course um for high school students in
vietnam
um so i teach um i'm sort of uh
i was born in vietnam i grew up here in
the us so i'm sort of bilingual and
vietnamese and english more english than
vietnamese
um and i you know what i learned about
science and biology i learned in english
so
um what we ended up is we we teach um
the vietnamese high school students in
vietnam as well so teaching is also my
my passion and mentor mentoring is my
passion as well so if you have any other
questions related to your career
you know um i would i cannot answer your
math question or your biology homework
or chemistry homework that i
don't think i could do but anything
related to you know
um what is going on in the field
apparently what is
what does this mean um then yes i'd love
to talk to you guys about
so like that i think i have at least my
email address
again um if you wanted to reach out to
me
with my address
awesome if there aren't any more
questions we can wrap it up
thank you all so much for coming and
participating
um hopefully you learned a thing or two
about antibodies um
going forward so now when you hear it on
the news or you see it on facebook
if you all do facebook or instagram i
don't know what whatever or tic tac
now you have an idea um we have another
question
uh lizette does being a scientist take
you a lot of time
for example sometimes the doctor don't
have much time for them
um i think so though
i think the the different about uh one
of the different things about
um being a scientist and a doctor is yes
it takes a lot of time
training and practicing so i think those
are both careers that can do quite
learning and practice um
and but in terms of in terms of training
that can take you for example phd
for six or more years so some people do
eight years i will do four years and go
three years
um that's after you do your college uh
four years of college
um and in terms of a day-to-day
a scientist can work between you know
three hours or 20 hours a day
um depends on the amount of work that
they they they
they need to do so i think both are um
both are you know time-consuming careers
but the
the difference is that i think
personality scientists have more
liberties of deciding on the day
deciding on the time uh define your
schedule
especially work in a setting like this
and setting like in
universities or in non-profit hospital
like this and you are more in charge of
your day
you can come to work and then for
example i have my coffee in the morning
that i made at home
i come in you know i come in at 9 30 i
come in at night coming 8 30
10 um but then the day takes me to where
i needed to
to end um i think doctors probably work
more hours than compared to scientists
um yeah and then some doctor is also
scientists so they also work in research
as well
so they have both the patient or the
clinical side and they also work in
research also scientists so
yeah it really depends on on the time of
work
and one fun fact about being a scientist
if you want to go into school
after college and you want to go to grad
school to get a phd degree
which takes about five to seven years um
if you do it in biomedical research or
biology or one of the science
sciences you actually don't pay for
school you get paid to go to school
if you go to medical school it's
different you have to get paid
um i think the reason why i love being a
scientist
is that you also have the flexibility of
doing many things after school
so you could decide to still work in a
laboratory you can decide to work in
policy
you can do consulting you can work with
industries so like johnson and johnson
or
pfizer or moderna so there are a lot of
different
options that you can do and you come
with a school
debt-free depending on what you did for
undergrad but it's definitely a perk
with
doing a phd in science in comparison to
doing an md
so keep that in mind if you're thinking
about going into stem there are many
different options
outside of being in medical doctor field
of science
yeah i think i think um both have um
great perks and you know there are you
know the careers that you know very
involved in
in discovery and practice and um
you know learning new things um there's
also path of the nd phd
you can do both you can be a doctor and
a scientist at the same time and that's
also free
it takes between six and eight years in
addition to to college
so the many paths is open to you you
don't have to get a phd to become a
scientist
people get a master's degree people
don't have a master's degree and they
decide to go deciduous
industry for a couple of years first and
the scientists there
um many many ways and you can be
involved
um insurance and be a scientist um
yeah so it takes time definitely
after you graduate um but
you know it's more like a journey
than a career
yeah awesome um
yeah thank you all for your questions um
thank you for participating thank you
evelyn for such a great presentation
um thank you for signing up um
and so yeah
thank you all right thank you all
right good day thank you weekend
enjoy the weekend bye guys
you